so
this is the first time i've told this
story in public the personal aspects of
it
and yogi berra was a world
famous baseball player who said if you
come to a fork in the road take it
researchers have been you know for more
than a century
studying the immune system as a way to
fight cancer
and cancer vaccines have unfortunately
been disappointing they've only worked
in
in cancers caused by viruses like
cervical cancer
or liver cancer so cancer researchers
basically gave up on the idea of using
the immune system to fight cancer
and the immune system in any case did
not evolve to
fight cancer it evolved to fight
pathogens invading from the outside
so its job is to kill bacteria and
viruses
and the reason the immune system has
trouble with most cancers
is that it's a can it doesn't evade from
the outside
it evolves from its own cells
and so the either immune system does not
recognize the cancer
as a problem or it attacks a cancer and
also our normal cells leading to
autoimmune diseases
like colitis or multiple sclerosis so
how do you get around that
our answer turned out to be synthetic
immune
systems that are designed to recognize
and kill cancer cells so that's right i
said a synthetic
immune system
you do that with genetic engineering and
synthetic biology
we did it with the naturally occurring
parts of the immune system called b
cells and t cells and these are our
building
blocks t cells have evolved to kill
cells infected with viruses
and b cells are those cells that make
antibodies that are secreted and then
bind to
to kill bacteria so well
what if you combine these two functions
in a way that was designed to repurpose
them to fight
cancer we realized it would be possible
to insert the genes for antibodies
from b cells into t cells so how do you
do that
well we used an hiv virus as a trojan
horse
to get past the t cell's immune system
the result is a chimera a fantastic fire
fire-breathing
creature from greek mythology with a
lion's head
a goat's body and a serpent's tail
so we decided that the paradoxical thing
that we had created
with our b cell antibodies our t cells
carrier and the hiv trojan horse should
be called
chimeric antigen receptor t cells or car
t
cells the virus also inserts
genetic information to activate the t
cells and programming them into
their killing mode so when car t cells
are injected into somebody with cancer
what happens when those car t cells see
and bind to their tumor target they act
like
supercharged killer t cells on steroids
they start this crash defense buildup
system in the body
and literally divide and multiply by the
millions
where they then attack and kill the
tumor all of this means that car t
cells are the first living drug in
medicine
car t cells break the mold unlike normal
drugs that you take
they do their job and get metabolized
and then you have to take them again
car t cells stay alive and on the job
for years
we have had car t cell stay in our
patients uh
in the bodies of our cancer patients now
for more than eight years
and these designer cancer t cells car t
cells have a calculated half-life of
more than 17 years
so one infusion can do the job they stay
on patrol for the rest of your life
this is the beginning of a new paradigm
in medicine
now there was one major challenge to
these t cell infusions the only
source of t cells that will work
in a patient are your own t cells unless
you happen to have an identical twin
so for most of us we're out of luck
um so what we did was to make car t
cells
we had to learn to grow the patient's
own t cells
and we developed a robust platform for
this in the 1990s
then in 1997 we first tested car t cells
in patients
with advanced hiv aids and we found that
those car t
cells survived in the patients for more
than a decade
and it improved their immune system and
decreased their viruses but it didn't
cure them
so we went back to the laboratory and
over the next decade made
improvements to the car t cell design
and by
2010 we began treating leukemia patients
and our dream treated three patients
with advanced
chronic lymphocytic leukemia in 2012.
it's a form of incurable leukemia
that afflicts approximately 20 000
adults every year in the united states
the first patient that we treated was a
retired
marine sergeant and a prison corrections
officer he had only weeks to live
and had in fact already paid for his
funeral
the cells were infused and within days
he had high fevers
he developed multiple organ failure was
transferred to the icu and was comatose
we thought he would die in fact he was
given last rites
but then another
fork in the road happened so around 28
days after the cart cell infusion he
woke up
and the physicians finally examined him
and the cancer was gone
the big masses that had been there had
melted
bone marrow biopsies found no evidence
of leukemia and that year
in our first three patients we treated
two of three have had durable remissions
now for eight years and one
had a partial remission the car t cells
had attacked
the leukemia in these patients and had
dissolved between
2.9 and 7.7 pounds of tumor in each
patient
their bio bodies had become veritable
bioreactors for these car t
cells producing millions and millions of
car t cells in the bone marrow blood and
tumor masses and we've discovered that
these car t cells can punch
far above their weight class to use a
boxing analogy
just one car t cell can kill a thousand
tumor cells so that's right it's a ratio
of a one
to a thousand the car t cell and its
dodge daughter progeny cells
can divide and divide and divide in the
body until the last tumor cell is gone
there's no precedent for this in cancer
medicine
the first two patients who had full
remission remain
today leukemia-free and we think they
are cured
these are people who had run out of
options
and by all traditional methods they had
they were like
modern day lazarus cases all i can say
is thank goodness for those
uh forks in the road our next step was
to get permission to treat
children with acute leukemia the most
common form of cancer in kids
the first patient we enrolled on the
trial was emily whitehead and at that
time she was six years old
she had gone through a series of
chemotherapy and radiation treatments
over several years and her leukemia had
always come back
and in fact it had come back three times
when we first saw her
emily was very ill
her official diagnosis was advanced in
curable leukemia
cancer had invaded her bone marrow her
liver her spleen
and when we infused her with the car t
cells in the spring of april
2012 over the next few days she did not
get better
she got worse and in fact much worse as
our prison
corrections officer had in 2010 she in
2012 was amid
the icu and this was the scariest fork
in the whole road
of this story by day three she was
comatose
and on life support for kidney failure
lung failure and coma her fever was as
high as 106 degrees
fahrenheit for three days and we didn't
know what was causing those fevers
we did all the standard blood tests for
infections and we could not find
an infectious cause for her fever but we
did find something very unusual
in her blood that had never been seen
before in madison
she had elevated uh levels of a protein
called
interleukin-6 or il-6 in her blood it
was
in fact more than a thousand-fold above
the normal levels and here's where yet
another fork in the road
came in um by
sheer coincidence one of my daughters
has a form of
pediatric arthritis
and as a result i'd been following as a
cancer doc
experimental therapies for arthritis for
my daughter
and in case you would need them and it
so happened that just months before
emily was in
the hospital a new therapy had been
approved by the fda to treat elevated
levels of interleukin-6
and it was approved for the arthritis
that my daughter had it's called
tosalisimab
um and in fact it had just been added to
the pharmacy
at emily's hospital um you know for
arthritis
so when we found emily had these very
high levels of aisle six i called her
doctors in icu and said
why don't you treat her with this
arthritis drug
they said i was a cowboy for suggesting
that and since her fever
and low blood pressure had not responded
to any other
therapy her doctor quickly asked
permission to the institutional review
board her parents and everybody of
course said
yes and they tried it and the
results were nothing short of striking
within hours after treatment of
tocilizumab emily began to improve
very rapidly 23 days after her
treatment she was declared cancer-free
and today she's
12 years old and still in remission
[Applause]
so we now call this violent reaction
with high fevers
and coma uh following car t cell
cytokine release syndrome or crs we've
found that occurs in nearly all patients
who respond to the therapy
but it does not happen in those patients
who fail to respond
so paradoxically our patients now
hope for these high fevers after therapy
that which feels like the worst flu in
their life
when they get car t cell therapy they
hope for this reaction because they know
it's part of the twisting and turning
path back to health unfortunately not
every patient recovers
patients who do not get crs are often
those who are not
cured so there's a strong link now
between crs
and the ability of the immune system to
eradicate leukemia
that's why last summer when the fda
approved
car t cells for leukemia
they also co-approved the use of
tocilizumab to block the il-6 results
her effects and the accompanying crs
in these patients that was a very
unusual event in medical history
emily's daughters doctors have now
completed
uh further trials and reported that 27
out of 30 patients the first 30 we
treated
or 90 had a complete remission
um um after car t cells within a month
a 90 complete remission rate in
patients with advanced cancer is unheard
of in more than 50 years
of cancer research in fact companies
often declare success in a cancer trial
if 15
of the patients have a complete response
rate a remarkable study appeared in the
new england journal of medicine in 2013
and the international study has since
confirmed those results
and that led to the approval of uh by
the fda
of for pediatric and young adult
leukemia in august of 2017.
so it was the first ever approval of a
cell and gene therapy
car t cell therapy has also been tested
now in in adults with refractory
lymphoma
this disease afflicts about 20 000 a
year in the united states
and the results were equally impressive
and and have been durable to date
and six months ago the fda approved the
therapy of this advanced lymphoma with
car t cells so now there are many labs
and physicians and scientists around the
world who've tested car t
cells across many different disease
diseases and understandably we're all
thrilled with the rapid pace of
advancement
we're so grateful to see patients who
are formerly uh terminal to return to
healthy
lives as emily has we're thrilled to see
long remissions that may in fact be a
cure
at the same time we're also concerned
about financial costs it can cost up to
150 000
to make the car t cells for each patient
and when you add in the cost of treating
crs and other complications the cost can
reach
one million dollars per patient we must
remember that the cost of failure though
is even worse
the current non-curative therapies for
cancer are also expensive and
and in addition the patient dies so of
course we'd like to see research done
now
to make this a more efficient and
affordability
and increase affordability to all
patients fortunately this is a new and
evolving field and as with many other
new
therapies and services prices will come
down as industry learns
to do things more efficiently when i
think about all the forks in the road
that have led to car t cell therapy
there is one thing that strikes me is
very important
we're reminded that discoveries of this
magnitude don't happen overnight
car t cell therapies came to us after a
30 year
journey along a road full of setbacks
and surprises
in all this world of instant
gratification and 24 7 on demand
results scientists require persistence
vision and patience to rise above all
that
they can see that the fork in the road
is not always
a dilemma or a detour sometimes even
though we may not know it at the time
the fork is the way home thank you very
[Applause]
much